GOOD MORNING. AND WELCOME TO
THIS ONLY COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
IN TAX I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. MR IF WE TAKE THE RAW.
BURKE HERE TO. GRAY LEVINE.
MACE MAYES HERE MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS
HERE QUIRK WILL WORK HERE RIVAS.
RIVAS HERE DOLLY. DOLLY HERE.
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STATE HOME ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AT THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL.
THERE WERE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATING HEARING
IN PERSON. WE ARE REQUIRED THE
MASTERY MORE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM FOR. THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITES. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CANNOT
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU ARE WE
CAN'T PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU
SORRY. WE CAN. IF WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. THOSE OF
PUBLIC INTEREST. FORTY TWO. I'M
SORRY IF. I'M SORRY MY FIRST
DAY BACK IN BUILDING AND IT'S
BEEN A FIVE. ROUGH COUPLE WEEKS.
TO THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AROUND FORTY TWO OH TWO TODAY
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STUFF AND
A LIMóN NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE MAINTAIN SIX FEET
OF SPACING. THEY'RE ALL DEAD
IT'S PROTOCOL FOR PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WITHOUT
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
THE SAID THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING ARE. TO
YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE HEARING ROOM
INCLUDING LIMITING. ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOR DIALING WITNESSES WE WILL
BE WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANYONE IS CAN
CALL TEST FIND A BILL FOR. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE TWO
OH TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY REVENUE
ATTACKS COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV. IF YOU ARE
GOING IN PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF YOUR BILL WOULD HAVE
BE TEST WILL. BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING AND IS BEGINNING
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. BASED ON WHAT
YOUR- SUPPORT OR THE BILL. IF
YOUR CALL I AM PLEASED. ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES.
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST ON
YOUR SMART. DEVICE TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE
THE MAIN WITNESS PRYING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU ARE MADE ON THE LIVE
LINE I WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF INTO YOU CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE AND PHONE
SERVICE IF YOU CAN CALL THE
COMEDIAN 916-319-2098 MY STUFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP
YOU. I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THE-
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US HER WITH ME AND WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT MATHIS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA Y. ALSO. BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE
THE. BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
BILL'S. JUST TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR BEING HERE I KNOW OUR JOB
IS IMPORTANT AND I KNOW WHAT WE
DO HERE IS IMPORTANT. MYSELF
HAS BEEN EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS
AND I'M RECOVERED BUT MY STAFF
HAS LOST FAMILY FROM THE VIRUS
WHILE WE WERE GONE. I
APPRECIATE THEIR CONTINUED WORK
IN SUPPORTING FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. SO YOU AND I WILL GET
THROUGH THIS TOGETHER TODAY
OKAY. NOW BEFORE WE TAKE UP ARE
FILLED FIRST BILL I LIKE TO DO
SOME ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE FOUR
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SPECIFICALLY ARE CONSENT
CALENDAR COMPRISES OF THE
FOLLOWING. FILE AND ONE SB
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR HILL.
FILE ITEM THREE SB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR MONNING. FILE
ITEM FOR SB NINE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES FILE ITEM SEVEN
SB ONE ONE FOUR ONE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. GALLAGHER WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR DOCTOR QUIRK AT
SECOND FROM MISTER MAYES. FOR
REGULAR NON CONSENT AGENDA WE
WILL TAKE TWO PRELIMINARY%
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TWO PRIMARY WHEN IS IN
OPPOSITION OR WITH CONCERNS
THESE WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY. WE'LL BE HEARING BILLS IN
THE ORDER SHOWN ON THE AGENDA
FINALLY. WELCOME DAWALY THIS
COMMITTEES USUALLY MUCH MORE
FUN THAN THE HOUSE- BUT AS
SHE'S BEEN APPOINTED TO FILL A
REPUBLICAN VACANCY FOR THE
HEARING AND WE WELCOME HER FOR.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM. SO
TWO ONE MOVED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE WOULD. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FALLING THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BURKE HI BURKE
HI CHIU I'VE CHIU AYE GRAY.
LEVINE MAYES MAYES HI MON.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
I WORK FOR WORK HI RIVAS RIVAS
HI DOLLY. DOLLY HI. CONSENT
COUNTERS ADOPTED HIS SON
CONNOR'S ADOPTED OF OUR FIRST
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR MITCHELL
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR WE PERCENT
TODAY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
IT'S WORTH. THANK YOU MEMBERS
I'M HONORED TO PRESENT SB THREE
SIX FOUR TODAY SB THREE SIX
FOUR WOULD EXTEND A CURRENT TAX
EXEMPTION OFFER TO SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS ON COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES IF THE PROPERTY IS
REASSESSED PROP FIFTEEN PASSES
THIS FALL. OPPOSITION SEVEN WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ALLOWING THE LEGISLATURE TO
EXEMPT SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS
FROM PROPERTY TAX. IN ORDER FOR
PROPERTY TAX REASSESSMENT IN
ORDER TO INCENTIVIZE CLEAN
ENERGY. UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS
EXEMPTION IS IN PLACE FOR
SYSTEMS STALLED THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AN UNINTENTIONAL
DRAFTING ERROR IN PROPOSITION
FIFTEEN REMOVES THE CURRENT
EXEMPTION. THIS WOULD FIX THE
PROBLEM BY ALLOWING SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS ON A COMMERCIAL
AND INDUSTRIAL PROPERTIES TO
CONTINUE TO BE EXEMPT FROM
PROPERTY TAX AND CHANGE IT ALL.
TYPICAL OR INTEL TWENTY TWELVE
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT LAW OFF. AS YOU AS YOU
RECALL. WAS PASSED IN THE
EIGHTY WE'VE SEEN A HUGE AMOUNT
SUCCESS IN SOLAR ENERGY
ADOPTION BECAUSE OF IT- AND
WE'VE NOW BECOME REALLY THE
CAPITAL OF. GREEN ENERGY HERE
IN THIS COUNTRY- THAT'S WHY WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IMPORTANT
FIXED IN CASE PROP FIFTEEN
PASSES. AND WITHOUT A RESPECT
AS FOR AYE VOTE WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
FOR PUT ON THE FILE. THEN WHY
HELLO FOODS. WITH KLAY ENERGY
WITH WITH CAP DYNAMIC AS WELL
AS BROWN WITH SEIU CA. WE HAVE
THE MOST BY MS JUNE SECOND BY
THIS RIVER MYSTERIES AND OKAY
THE FIRST. WITNESS THE PRIMARY
WHEN THIS WILL BE MR ALLEN
WHO'S WITH CAPITAL DYNAMICS
WHICH YOU WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE THANKS MISTER ALLEN WHO.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU THINK YOU. RIGHT MY NAME IS
BEN WHILE THEY I WORK AT CATTLE
DYNAMICS I'M AN INVESTOR
MANAGER SPECIALIZED IN CLEAN
ENERGY- WE ARE ONE OF THE
LARGEST INVESTORS IN RENEWABLE
ENERGY IN THE OS. WITH A
SIGNIFICANT PORTFOLIO
CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF OUR
LARGEST INVESTORS IS CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PENSION PLAN. WE'RE
HERE TODAY WORKING WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF PROP FIFTY IN AND
OUT LIKE TO THANK. YOU WE NEED
TO REPAIR AN INADVERTENT
OVERRIDE OF PROP SEVEN. WHICH
OF ASSEMBLY JAMES SAID WAS
ABOUT BY VOTERS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TO EXCLUDE SO AQUATIC
UMBRELLA PROPERTY TAXES. SB
EIGHT ONE THREE WITH MAINTAINED
EXCLUSION- SB TRIPLE SIX TARGET
WOULD MAKE EXCLUSION NOTHING
MORE NOTHING LESS. DESTRUCTIVE
CORN FOR PRODUCTS ON THE
CONSTRUCTION THAT FACE
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY. SOLO
PROJECT BUILT AFTER TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR WILL PAY
PROPERTY TAXES IN FULL. IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE SEVEN
PATIENTS CLEAN ENERGY GOAL- AND
WE WILL NEED TO BUILD. THE
PROXIMITY TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
TO THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
MEGAWATT AT. WHEN YOU WILL
GENERAL IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
SO I'M ASKING YOU TO HELP US
STAY ON TRACK. BY BUILDING OUT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THERE'S
OUR SECOND WHEN IT IS AS IF
YOU'RE IN PERSON- TERRY BRENNAN
WITH I SEE ARE YOU. TERRY
BRENNAN BEHALF OF FE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA- WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID A GREAT JOB
OF EXPLAINING AND IT WAS AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF THE-
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY FIRST
INITIATIVE THIS IS BASICALLY A
NO HARM NO FOUL. ADJUSTMENT BUT
TO MAKE SURE DON'T IMPACT THE
IMPORTANT THAT SOLAR INDUSTRY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I AM I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION WITH
THE MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT IS
NOW WITH- JESSE SALINAS OF YOLO
COUNTY SAN. AND JUST HELLO GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK YOU
HELLO GOOD MORNING CHAIR BURKE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JESSE SALINAS AND I AM THE
COUNTY ASSESSOR FOR YOLO
COUNTY. AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SENSORS ASSOCIATION. I'M HERE
TO SHARE OUR OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE SIXTY FOUR. THERE ARE
THREE KEY REASONS FOR THIS
OPPOSITION. FIRST THE
LEGISLATURE THE LEGISLATION
ATTEMPT TO REDEFINE ACTIVE
SOLAR SYSTEM FOR REAL PROPERTY
IMPROVEMENT TO PERSONAL
PROPERTY. WHICH WE BELIEVE TO
BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL BASED ON
PAT COURT CASES ON THIS TOPIC.
NUMBER TWO THIS BILL TOOK A BAD
PRECEDENT BY CHANGING THE
CATEGORIZATION OF ACTORS SOLAR
SYSTEMS BERMAN EXCLUSION TO AN
EXEMPTION. SUCH A WEEK. WILLING
OTHER SPECIAL INTEREST TO
FOLLOW SUIT AND WILL CALL THE
FUTURE EROSION OF THE PROPERTY
TAX BASE. FINALLY BILL IS BEING
PUT FORTH IN THE EVENT
PROPOSITION FIFTEEN ALSO KNOWN
AS THE SPLIT ROLE PASSES WE ASK
THAT YOU NOT PUT THE HOT DOG
SORRY THE HORSE BEFORE THE CART
INSTEAD WAIT TO SEE IF THE
ISSUE THE PASSAGE IF IT DOES
PASS WE CAN TAKE TIME HELLO
NEXT LOGICAL QUESTION TO
PROPERLY THAT THE ISSUES AND
CONCERNS EXPRESSED. BY SUCH AS
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU- AT THIS
TIME IF THE MODERATOR WOULD
PLEASE NOW OPEN UP THE MAIN
LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND FIRST
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING I
CHAIR MEMBERS AND I THOUGHT YOU
DOLLARS. HERE ON BEHALF LOS
ANGELES IDIOT ON THE MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI SUPPORT AT AT THE-
WHAT THANK YOU. THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN UP. I
IMMEDIATELY ON BEHALF OF TESLA
AND SUPPORT. BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE ONE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
DON'T HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORED VOCATION IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER EIGHTEEN LINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BLIND
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN INSTRUCTABLE
BOTTOM LINE TWENTY TWO BY
TWENTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING BILL THE FERRARI
ON BEHALF OF SOME POWER
CORPORATION IN SUPPORT. AND
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER TWENTY ONE
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SURE MEMBER CATALINA FAN
SAYS THAT WITH CARBON KAISER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER. THIRTY FIVE LINE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TERM MEMBER TODD TRITON
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION ARE IS ALL VOTE
SOLAR IN CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT LINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS BILL MCGAVIN
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT ALTER
MY NUMBER TWENTY FOUR BY TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR DELANEY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
EDS RENEWABLE EDP WERE NOBLE
AND FOR SOLAR ON STRUCK THE
PORT. AND NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BRETT
MARROW WITH HIS POWER HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER NINETEEN MY
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JAKE AND
I GREW AT IN GILBERT AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL CAN CHOICE
ASSOCIATE ALL IN. ENACT OPEN
LINE FORTY LINE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS WERE A MODEL WITH
THE WHY GRIP ON OF THE CURRENT
ENERGY IN SUPPORT. AND AS A
REMINDER TWENTY ONE BLACK TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE A FEW
PEOPLE OF CUED UP THERE WITH
GREATER. AND A TO OPEN MY
NUMBER FORTY TWO LINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU CAN FIND
FROM THE PORT. AND NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR LINE THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JADEN
BARBERS WITH UNION CONTENT
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT. AND THAT
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
SHOWING SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
APOLOGIZE WE HAVE A SECOND
WITNESS- IN OPPOSITION- IS ROB
LASTLY OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE ON THE LINE.
IF SO WITH THE MODERATOR PUSHER
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING SORRY
ABOUT THAT. NOW THANK YOU IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE WITH YOU- MY
NAME IS ROB LAPSLEY I'M
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE I'M HERE
TODAY TO JOIN WITH THE COUNTY
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA TO OPPOSE SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR. GB RG SUPPORT
ACTIVE SOLAR SYSTEMS CONTINUE
TO HAVE AN EXCLUSION FROM
PROPERTY TAXES CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT LAW THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND WE SUPPORT THAT
THAT IS WHY WE ARE PART OF A
BROAD BASED COALITION TODAY.
ACTUALLY OPPOSING PROP FIFTEEN
ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT PROP
FIFTY IS POORLY DRAFTED HAS A
SERIES OF MAJOR FLAWS INCLUDING
REMOVING EXISTING
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS FOR
THE INSTALLATION FOR THE
INSTALLATION OF NEW ACTORS
SOLAR SYSTEMS. WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM
PROPERTY TAXATION UNTIL THERE'S
A CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP. UNDER
PROP FIFTEEN COMMERCIAL ACTORS
SOLAR SYSTEMS WILL BE TAXES
THAT PRAYER MARKET VALUE AS
OFTEN AS EVERY YEAR BUT AT
LEAST EVERY THREE YEARS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THREE SIXTY FOUR
BECAUSE CLEARLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND FLIES IN
THE FACE OF DECADES OF THOSE
THAT WAS CASE LAW. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA
COURT STRUCK DOWN A SIMILAR
ACCOUNT BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
CIRCUMVENT THE CONSTITUTION AND
LUCAS PERSON MONTEREY THE COURT
FOUND THAT THE LEGISLATION
ATTEMPTING TO RE CLASS BY BOAT
SLIPS SO THEY ARE NO LONGER
PROPERLY BE AN EXAM FROM
STATION GOES ON. TO MANDATE A
CON ISN'T SB THREE SIXTY THE
TEMPTING AND PROPOSING TO DO
THE SAME THING THAT WAS STRUCK
DOWN BY THE COURTS DECADES AGO.
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR FOR THE DAY
TRUSTED ALLOWING THE
LEGISLATURE PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS. PROPERTY TWO SO
PROTECTIONS IN A MERE STATUTORY
ONE LEAVING MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S CRITICAL
INDUSTRIES AT THE MERCY. OF THE
LET GREATER. PROPERTY TAKE
CARES APPLE OVER THREE
RESTAURANT SMALL BUSINESS AND
DAIRY JUST A FEW RIGHT NOW MOST
OF THOSE IN YOUR DON'T EVEN
THAT THAT FIRST OR JUST TO
SERVE AND YOU KNOW HAVE THE TO
MYBUT IN TO GET THE TWO OF CAR
THE SO INTO IS THAT FOR TODAY
SO WITH SB THIRTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR IT'S CLEARLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL OPPOSED BY
CALIFORNIA'S ASSESSORS
ASSOCIATION AND JUST BAD PUBLIC
POLICY FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE NOW
OPEN THE MAINLAND FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION TO HER
TESTIMONY. WHERE TO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ELECT TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE HAVE A
ONE CRITICISM OF AN OPERATOR.
AN OPEN LINE OF LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN NINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN.GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
ROBERTS PEOPLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN HAVE A REMINDER IF
YOU LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS LONDON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PARTICIPANTS SHOWING
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR QUIRK WELCOME BACK. WITH
SOMEONE ON THE SUPPORT SIDE
DRESSED. ISSUE ISSUE. THE
CHANCES THAT THE COURT PRESENT
OF THE THIS WOULD BE ON. SO
THANK YOU FOR THE DOCTOR YOU
KNOW WHICH RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH MY IN A FORMER
ASSESSOR COLLEAGUES- AGAIN THIS
IS A- THIS IS TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE WILL
OF THE VOTERS. THE PROPOSITION
THAT WAS PASSED BY THE VOTERS
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY. IT IS A
VERY NARROW VERY SPECIFIC FIX-
BASED ON THE BUT HOW IN A BASED
ON HOW PROPOSITION FIFTEEN WAS
WRITTEN. AND SO AGAIN- ON THERE
IS CASE LAW WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THE WILL OF THE VOTERS-
REALLY ULTIMATELY IS WHAT
STANCE AND SO BECAUSE THIS.
ACCIDENTALLY OVER RIGHTS THAT
WILL THE VOTERS- THIS BILL
WOULD CONTINUE TO PRESERVE THAT
WILL IN GOING FORWARD TOLD
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AGAIN. THIS
IS ONLY FOR SOLAR SYSTEMS AND
ONLY IF THEY- DIDN'T CHANGE DID
NOT CHANGE OWNERSHIP SO IT'S A
VERY SMALL. THE LIST OF
PROPERTIES. OKAY THANK YOU BUT
IT SOUNDS AS IF YOU AGREE THAT
THIS COURT CASES THAT. HE THE
JUDGES DECIDE TO FOLLOW THE
COURT'S PREVIOUS COURT CASES AS
A POWER TO. THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS THIS BILL. YEAH I
HAVEN'T FOLLOWED THE SPECIFIC
WORKERS OR FOR ANY OF THE
SUPPORTERS WANT TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THAT COURT CASE AND
HAPPY TO LET THEM. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE SOMEONE COMING TO MAKE
THEM. MELCHER MEMBERS JERRY
BROWN ON BEHALF OF SCA YOU
AGAIN- WE'VE ASKED OUR
ATTORNEYS THE LAW FIRM A- RAM
SHOW AND ALSO IN. THEY'VE
REVIEWED THIS AND ITS
RELATIONSHIP. IS CONSTITUTIONAL
AND THEREFORE THE ARGUMENT SO
DON'T NEED TO MUSTER. EVERY
SEMESTER I THOUGHT. MYSTERIES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. SO I'M
STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT WITH
THIS ONE AND TO BE HONEST- AND
IT'S BECAUSE I LOVE SOLAR- I
COME FROM A RIVERSIDE AND SAN
BENITO COUNTY AND WE HAVE AN
AWFUL LOT OF SUNSHINE AND WE
HAVE AN AWFUL LOT OF LAND- AND
WE HAVE MADE INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
OF SOUL DEVELOPS I'M A BIG BIG
FAN OF. OF SOLAR I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE VOTERS-
HAVE- AB IT HAD AGREED WITH
SOME LANGUAGE- BUT IT JUST
SEEMS ODD TO ME- A COUPLE
THINGS YOU MIGHT ACTUALLY BUT
THE ONE THING THAT WE DON'T
QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS WHY
NOW- WHY ARE WE DOING THIS NOW
AND WHERE WE DOING THIS- AFTER
NOVEMBER WHY WOULD WE DO THIS
NEXT YEAR IF IT WAS. IT IS
NECESSARY AND I DO HAVE A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS. NO I'M
NOT GONNA LET ADVOCATES-
RESTAURANTS PACIFICA CHEVRON
THEY THINK YOU MIGHT AS WELL.
JUST STAY UP HERE I THINK WE
HAVE A SERIES OF QUESTIONS I
THINK THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS.
HELLO CAN I ANSWER THIS
QUESTION. ABSOLUTELY CORRECT-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION- IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT COUPLE THAT I MAKES
IS BUILDING B. E. LONG PROJECT-
JUST NORTH OF LA IT'S ONE OF
THE LOWEST PRICE IN THE WORLD-
VERY LARGE PROJECT. EMPLOYEES
UNIONIZED LABOR. AS IT STANDS
NOW THE FINANCING IS COMPLETELY
FROZEN THE UNCERTAINTY ON
PROPERTY TAX IT IS A MAJOR
ISSUES O- UNFORTUNATELY TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE- AND. HAT ON
THIRTIETH SOME POINT IS GOING
TO START KILLING PROJECTS. NOT
JUST BEYOND YOU KNOW WE WORK
WITH A LOT OF. FATHER. WHEN YOU
BUDGET BUSTERS SO I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE ANY JOB LOSSES. BECAUSE
BASICALLY OF UNCERTAINTY AND IN
IN PROPERTY TAXES. THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE THE SIMILARITIES HAS
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT YEAH THEN I CAN
THIS IS THE END THIS IS BY THE
WAY INCREDIBLY AWKWARD AS WE.
ALL KNOW AND COMMITTEE BECAUSE
OF OUR SOCIAL DISTANCING ALL
THINGS ARE TO. IT MAKES LEDGES
INCREDIBLY DE MAKES THE FLOW OF
IN. A VERY VERY DIFFICULT AND
SO A PLEASE FORGIVE ME FOR EVEN
HAVING THESE QUESTIONS I WISH I
COULD HAVE GOT SOME ANSWERED-
BEFORE- BUT IT DOES SEEM WHEN I
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE IS. A
LANGUAGE. WE'RE DEFINING. WHAT
IS KNOWN TODAY AS REAL
PROPERTY. AND WE'RE FINDING IT
AS PERSONAL PROPERTY. SO THAT
IF IN INITIATIVE THE GETS
PASSED IN NOVEMBER THIS WOULD
THEN BECOME BECOME A BIG
EXEMPTS AND YET. EVEN IN THE
LANGUAGE ITSELF FOR SAYING IT'S
ONLY GOING TO BE DEFINED AS
PERSONAL PROPERTY INTEL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND THEN AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I WANT TO
MAKE ONE MAKE SURE I GET THIS
CORRECTLY CORRECT THAT AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE'RE GOING
TO IT'S GONNA BE DEFINED AS
REAL PROPERTY AGAIN. SO IT
SEEMS LIKE WE MIGHT BE JUMPING
THROUGH SOME HOOPS HERE- BUT
BECAUSE THE AN INITIATIVE
WASN'T CRAFTED APPROPRIATE MY
ON TO SOMETHING HERE OR MY
MISSING SOMETHING. THIS IS ALL
IN ALL THIS IS A FORM. CARRIER
THIS IS NOT THE- IS THIS NEW
WASN'T HE BEST WAY TO DRAFT IT
I'D SAY THAT THIS IS THE- WAY
TO DRAFT ITTOO AGAIN
MAINTAINED THE DESIRED THE
VOTERS THAT FOR THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY- YOU KNOW WE- WE DON'T
ALWAYS GET TO LEGISLATE THE
PERFECT LEGISLATION I THINK
THIS IS THE WE DECIDED- THIS
WAS THE BEST WAY TO AGAIN- MAKE
SURE THAT WE MAINTAIN THE WILL
OF THE VOTERS- THAT WE CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT A VERY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY THAT WAS.
INADVERTENTLY HARM TO BY THE
POTENTIAL BALLOT INITIATIVE AND
SO THIS WAY- YOU KNOW WE COULD
DO BOTH I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
THAT IT IS NOT IT IS NOT A
PERFECT SOLUTION BUT VERY
RARELY DO WE HAVE PERFECT
SOLUTIONS IN OUR LEGISLATURE
ISN'T ENOUGH TO CAN MANAGER
JUST ONE ON ONE MORE QUESTION
IS THERE ANOTHER WAY TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THIS OTHER THAN- IT
WRITTEN AGAIN IT SEEMS PRETTY
SLOPPY TO MEAN- THAT WE WOULD
BE RUNNING A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS AT THE AT
THIS IS OR SOME OTHER WAY TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF. THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. THEN THROUGH.
IT WHAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE
INTELLECTUALLY DISHONEST YEAH
SO- LOOK AS AS A FORMER. COUNTY
ASSESSOR I ASSURED- DECLARE.
THE IN OUR FULL WAY THAT THIS
WAS DONE WITH MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES- WE DID CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE THAT WAS EVEN BROADER
IN- AB ONE OH FIVE SO THAT'S
WHY WE'RE DOING THE SB THREE
SIX WAR. SO WE DID FURTHER
NARAL WHERE. TO AGAIN ONLY. BE
CONSISTENT WITH PROPOSITION
SEVEN FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY- SO
WE DID THAT BUT IT BUT AGAIN-
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO FIND
ANOTHER WAY TO MAINTAIN A AND
THE WILL OF THE VOTER. FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR SALT- SO
THIS WAS- THE BEST WAY THAT WE
COULD. WE COULD DO ABOUT STILL
MAINTAIN THAT CONSISTENCY. YES
WE DO WE DID EXPLORE OTHER
OPTIONS THERE'S NO QUESTION. MR
GREAT ARE YOU ARE YOU- MISTER
GRAY YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU FIRST
THING APPRECIATE THE COURTESY
THAT YOU'VE AFFORDED THE SENATE
IN PRESENTING THIS BILL FOR THE
OFFICE. UNFORTUNATELY I THINK.
MY COLLEAGUE RAISES IMPORTANT
ISSUES ABOUT THE BOTH
INTELLECTUAL HONESTY OR
DISHONESTY- CONTAINED IN THIS
APPROACH ALTHOUGH I ALSO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF MERIT IN WHAT'S BEING
DONE. IN THIS LEGISLATION. BUT
THERE'S BEEN REAL MIXED MESSAGE
FROM THE STATE SENATE. ON HOW
WERE PRIORITIZING. LEGISLATION
DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS-
THAT'S ON PRESIDENT. AND I KNOW
I'VE PUT LEGISLATION FORWARD IN
THE STATE SENATE THAT WOULD
RAISE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BY BRING IN BLACK
MARKET ACTIVITIES- I'VE PUT
LEGISLATION THE SENATE TO. DEAL
WITH THE EPIDEMIC OF YOUTH
VAPING THE SENATE'S NOT SEEN
THE WISDOM AND EVEN HEARING.
THOSE PIECE OF LEGISLATION. SO
AS OF TODAY DESPITE THE MERITS
CONTAIN THIS BILL AND CERTAINLY
NO REFLECTION ON YOU MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BUT A REFLECTION ON THE STATE
SENATE I WILL BE SUPPORTING ANY.
ESPY'S AT THIS TIME UNTIL WE
CAN GET. SOME RATIONAL.
AGREEMENT WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
ON HOW TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS SO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION BUT I
WILL BE SUPPORTED. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YEAH I THINK VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR- THANK YOU. MISTER KING
FOR A PRESENT IN THIS BILL I
SHARE A LOT OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE JUST HEARD FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM MERCED. THE
SENATE IS FAILING US AND IS
FEELING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE GIVING GOOD TIME. RIGHT
HERE TO TALK ABOUT A POLICY ONE
WHICH I AGREE WITH AND THAT I
WILL VOTE FOR TODAY BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO. FOCUS ON THE VOTE
BEFORE ME. BUT ONE THAT IS NOT
GOING TO IMPACT US MAYBE EVER.
IN LESS PROP FIFTEEN PASSES AND
THEN WE HAVE BEEN TOLD TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. TO DECIDE WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND WE'RE WE'RE
LISTENING TO THIS LEGISLATION
WERE GIVING DEBATE TO THIS
LEGISLATION WERE AIRING THE
POLICY OUT. AND WE SHOULD NOT
BE TODAY. CERTAINLY I AS OUR
COLLEAGUES STATED WITH THE
SENATE NOT TAKING UP
LEGISLATION GERMANE TO ISSUES
THAT ARE RIGHT IN FRONT OF US
TODAY. THE HEALTH COMMITTEE IS
NOT EVEN THE GEN DIS SEEN MY
BILL ON SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. BGO COMMITTEE IS
NOT LISTENING IS NOT SCHEDULING
MY BILL ON PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT OFFICE- AND YET WORSE
SPENDING TIME ON A BILL THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT. HAVE ANY IMPACT
ON US AND IF IT DOES UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. SO I FEEL
LIKE WE'RE WASTING IN. GOOD
TIME OR WE'RE DOING OUR JOB IN
THE SENATE IS NOT UP TO THIS
MOMENT. THANK YOU. QUIRK. BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO DON'T WANT
TO VOTE FOR THIS NOW I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT. YOU KNOW THIS
THIS YEAR IT'S JUST BEEN AWFUL.
AND I'M NOT. I'M GONNA BE
VOTING THE BILL AND FRANKLY THE
SENATE SIMPLY DOESN'T HAVE THE
BANDWIDTH TO HEAR ALL THE BELLS
AND MAYBE. SOME DECISIONS YOU
DON'T LIVE. BUT SENSE TO- NOT
BAD FOR A BILL THAT YOU LIKE.
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T GET WHAT YOU
WANT OUT OF THE SENATE I WOULD
ASK YOU TO RECONSIDER AND VOTE
ON THE MERITS OF THE BELL AND
THIS DOES NEED TO GET DONE NOW.
FOR THE REASONS THAT WE HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORTERS THAT. TO GO
FORWARD WITH SOME PROJECTS
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE
SOME CLARITY ON THIS. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE IT UP
NOW RATHER THAN AFTER AND PASS
AND THEN IT GOES INTO EFFECT.
WHEN THE- PROPOSITION GOES INTO
EFFECT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SO FOR
CLARITY PURPOSES FOR THOSE WHO
ARE- CONCERN ABOUT THE SENATE
THIS THIS BILL WAS REQUESTED
THAT WE HEAR TODAY BY
LEADERSHIP SO OUR LEADERSHIP-
SO FOR THOSE WHO ARE CONCERNED-
HAVE QUESTIONS. I TO I'M NOT
SURE THAT I WOULD HAVE WANTED
TO HEAR THIS BILL AT THIS TIME
HOWEVER. APPARENTLY IT'S
NECESSARY TODAY SO WITH THAT
LET'S MISTER OF WE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR BURKE. BURKE BY CHU.
CHU BY GRAY. GRAY NOT VOTING
LEVINE HI LEVINE I MAYES. MAYES
NOT VOTING MULLIN.
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS
NOT VOTING QUIRK WELL QUIRK I
RIVAS RIVAS HI DAWALY NOW DOLLY
NOW. THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
IT'S ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE NEXT STEP WE HAVE
FILE ITEM- FIVE SB NINE SEMI TO
MY SKINNER I'LL BE PRESENTING
THE BILL ON SKINNER'S BEHALF
TODAY AND DOCTOR QUIRK WILL BE
TAKING OVER AS CHAIR. CAN I
PRESENT FROM HERE. YOU ANY
LONGER THAN CARE. STATE COOL
THANKS. THEN AFTER WE'VE HAD
OUR GROUP THERAPY AND IT WILL
THIS BE LEAD OF THE CONCERNS
WHERE I PRESENT FROM. BUT THANK
YOU DOCTOR QUIRK AND MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED A PERCENT SB NINE
SEVEN TWO BY SENATOR SKINNER
BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THE CENTERS. HAS AGREED
TO TAKE THE FOLLOWING TO A
MEMBER. FIRST INSTEAD OF
PUBLISHING THE COMPLETE LIST OF
TAXPAYERS AND COMPANY
INFORMATION ON MTV'S WEBSITE
THE INFORMATION REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL SHOULD BE PROVIDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION. AND THE
SENATE GOVERNMENT'S GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE. SECOND
THE IMP. WILL BE AND- WILL
INCLUDE THIS. TYPE OF TAX
CREDITS CLAIMED BY THE
TAXPAYER. WITH THAT SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO IS DESIGNED TO GIVE
POLICYMAKERS AND THE PUBLIC THE
ABILITY DISCUSS EVALUATE AND
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
THE VERY TAX POLICIES WE
DISCUSSED. SO OFTEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE. UNFORTUNATELY HAVE
LIMIT I. TO SPECIFIC TAX
INFORMATION WE DO NOT KNOW WHO
IS CLAIMING CERTAIN TAX CREDITS
AND WE DO NOT KNOW HOW MUCH IS
BEING CLAIMED. WITH THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS SB NINE TO
ME TO ACQUIRE THE F. TO BE TO
COMPILE A LIST OF TAX PAYERS
SUBJECT TO THE CORPORATE TAX
WITH AT LEAST FIVE BILLION IN
GROSS RECEIPTS. ALONG WITH THE
FOLLOWING INFORMATION. THE
TAXPAYER'S NAME AS REPORTED ON
THE RETURN THE TOTAL TAX
LIABILITY. TOTAL AMOUNT OF
CREDITS AND THE TYPE OF CREDITS
CLEAN BY THE TAXPAYER. SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO DOES NOT RAISE
TAXES OR ELIMINATE CREDITS IT
JUST GIVES INFORMATION. LIST
LEVEL OF ACCESS TO SPECIFIC
TAXPAYER INFORMATION IS NOT
UNPRECEDENTED SEVERAL STATES
ALREADY REQUIRE SOME DISCLOSURE
OF SPECIFIC TAXPAYER
INFORMATION. WHEN CLEAVING
SPECIFICS STATE TAX CREDITS. IN
FACT CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX
CREDIT ON THE FILM TAX CREDIT
BOTH ALREADY REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE OF SPECIFIC
INFORMATION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW CERTAIN STEPS.
INFLUENCE BEHAVIOR.
UNFORTUNATELY SPECIFIC TAX
PAYER INFORMATION IS LIMITED TO
A HANDFUL OF TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS. WE SOMETIMES LACK THE
HARD DATA ON CALIFORNIA'S TAX
CREDITS AND THAT IS WHY SB SET
NINE SEVENTY TWO IS NEEDED SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE
INFORMATION. ON TAX CREDIT
GIVEN THE STATE. ON BEHALF OF
CENTER SKINNER I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I. VERY WELL. I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF HEARING
TODAY IN PERSON. MISTER TERRY
FERNANDO OF SEIU MISTER BRENNAN
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU MEMBERS TERRY BRANHAM HALF
OF SCO YOU CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL THAT ASK FOR TWO
DATA POINTS TO ASSIST THE
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD ON
DEALING WITH TAX EXPENDITURES.
HAVING BEEN PASSED IN THE IN
THE PAST FOR GOING FORWARD IN
THE FUTURE. IT SIMPLY DIVULGES.
FROM THE LARGEST BASICALLY
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED LARGEST
TAXPAYERS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
BASICALLY GAS WHICH TAX CREDITS
YOU TAKING ADVANTAGE OF AND
WHAT YOUR TAX LIABILITY IT'S
NOT A COMPLETE RELEASE OF THE
TAX RETURNS THERE'S NO TRADE
SECRETS YOU KNOW EXPOSED IT
SIMPLY TO HELP US DO THE SAME
THING WE COULD DO AT THE
FEDERALLEVEL AND SEVERAL THE
STATE WHICH IS HAVE THE
INFORMATION.TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT TAX EXPENDITURES THANK
YOU. WHAT'S GOING ON. WHAT
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE MALL
LINE TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND FOR TO OPEN A LINE OF
LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. REMEMBER
CATTLE IN AGAIN SAYS LOOK FOR
MANY CRIED THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR
NEXT PROJECT THE BAND BACK TO
OPEN MY NUMBER FIFTY ONE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YEAH DO
YOU HEAR ME. THIS IS A HOLLOW
GOMEZ- I'D GET UP IN THE LORD'S
WORK A FOUNDATION WHERE IN
SUPPORT AT AT THE- PORTANTINO
NINE. WE HAVE SUBMITTED A
COALITION LETTER WITH AND TOP
POVERTY PARTNERS. AND ARE ON
THE LINE AND TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I'M NOT A HIGHLIGHTS. I
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR NEXT TO
SPEND. AND NEXT OPEN A LINE OF
LINE NUMBER FIFTY FIVE ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. I CAN HEAR ME. ONE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
KATIE HARDWARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. AND AS A REMINDER
SELECT ACTUAL SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS LONDON ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR AN EXPERT
EVIDENCE. TAX OPEN MY NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
INCOME A FAILURE OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. BUT ENACT
AUTOMATICALLY SIX ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE BOMB
ON THE DOCK OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
STOCK BECAUSE. AND AT THE TIME
WE HAVE NO NO SHOWING SUPPORT
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL THE
STANDARD TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THE FIRST IS
PRESENT TELLING FOR COMP TIA
WAS APPEARING IN PERSON MR
RETALIATE WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MADAM CHAIR- CHRISTMAS KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED- WITH
THE AMENDMENTS IF I UNDERSTAND
IT CORRECTLY AND WOULD
APPRECIATE CLARIFICATION- UNDER
EXISTING LAW- THE CHEERS OF THE
TWO OUR C. COMMITTEES ALREADY
HAVE A FORTY. TO ACCESS ANY
TAXPAYER SPECIFIC DATA IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ALLOW THE
PUBLIC TO GAIN ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION. WOULD ANYONE BE
ABLE TO CONFIRM THAT WERE. YES
PUBLIC WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION AND ON THAT BASIS
MADAM CHAIR WE WOULD CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
BREAKS WITH- CONFIDENTIALITY
FOR TAXPAYERS IN THE STATE
WHICH WE HAVE LONG HELD- THE
TWO EXAMPLES THAT WERE CITED
THE PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT IN
CAL COMPETES. OR BOTH ONES IN
WHICH TAX PAYERS- COMPETE FOR
THOSE CREDITS AND THEY APPLY
FOR THE KNOW WHAT IS SUBJECT TO
THEIR APPLICATION- AND I DIDN'T
XIN. ON A TAXPAYERS BAY. OTHER
TO CREDITS AND INCENTIVES ARE
NOT ON THAT BASIS AND DON'T
FOLLOW IT AND THEREFORE
SHOULDN'T BE SUBJECT TO IT. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THAT
INFORMATION ALBEIT LIMITED- IS
DETRIMENTAL TO TAXPAYERS BUT IT
DOESN'T GIVE EITHER YOU OR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE FULL
STORY. YOU HAVE IN YOUR
POSSESSION. A SENATE BILL NINE
FIVE SIX BY JACKSON WE ARE NOT
FANS OF WHITE. BUT YOU'LL NOTE
THAT THERE'S EXTENSIVE WE WOULD
REQUEST MORE METRICS FOR
EVALUATING EFFECTIVENESS. THE
BITS OF INFORMATION THAT YOU
WOULD GET UNDER THIS BILL ARE
NOT GOING TO HELP THIS CALL
MAYBE FOR THE STATE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
DETERMINE OR ANSWER THE
QUESTION. ARE THESE TAX
INCENTIVES EFFECTIVE OR NOT AND.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE CONTINUE
TO A IS THE BAY AS- TO BE
AMENDED BY THE AUTHOR. THE
MANAGER. DALY I UNDERSTAND THIS
PRIMARY OPPOSITE WITNESS IS
PETER BLAH WITHOUT TAX WILL BE
TESTED BY TELL. WITH THE
MONTEREY PLEASE CONNECT THIS
NOW WITH ME BLOCK THAT. I
WANTED MORTGAGE YOUR- MORTGAGE
YOUR MEMBERS WE THANK YOU FOR.
FORTY OPPORTUNITY TODAY- CAP.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO CAL TAX AND
ALSO A LARGE ISSUES YOU SEE
TAXPAYERS THIS BILL AND LIKE
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER WATERPROOF
THE AMENDMENTS. WE'LL REVIEW
OPPOSED BECAUSE SO ALL WE BOTH
MAYBE MAKE COPIES TRACTOR.
AVAILABLE TO THE YOU VIOLATION
OF. FUNDAMENTAL FOOTBALL TALK
COMPANY. THE CAL TAX BILL
RIGHTS IT'S ALL IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS WHAT WE
CONFIDENTIAL. NOT ONLY TRADED
COMPANIES BUT PRIVATE COMPANIES
AS WELL. AND IT NOT CLEAR WHY
DESTRUCTIVE STEP AND YOU NEED
TO BE TAKEN LAWMAKERS CURRENTLY
AFFECT ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION- AND MORE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
EVALUATE TAX PARTICULAR CURRENT
LAW DEPARTMENT FINANCE
SEPTEMBER BY LEGISLATURE WITH
REPORT CONTACT THE STANDARD
USES MAKING SEVENTY ONE. AND
AGGREGATE DATA IS FAR MORE
USEFUL. DECISIONS RELATED TAX
CREDIT THAN ANY INFORMATION
RELATED BY UP DISCLOSED BY THIS
BILL. MASON A WE HAVE CONCERNS
CONCERNS THAT IF THIS MEETING-
FIRST OF ALL THEY MEET FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS DOLLAR GROSS
RECEIPTS THRESHOLD IS BASED ON
TOTAL GROSS YOUR SEATS
WORLDWIDE BUT THE TAX LIABILITY
LIST BASED ON THE COMPANY'S
CALIFORNIA SALES. RIGHT WE
START CAN BE USED TO MY
UNDERSTAND THE TAX LIABILITY
THEIR VALUE WE HAS LITTLE TO DO
WITH THE SIZE THE COMPANY
RELATIONWITH RUSSELL. EXACTLY
THERE'S NO CONTACT GIVEN
REGARDLESS TAX CREDITS NO
PERFORMANCE METRICS-DATA
DEMONSTRATING WHAT ADDITIONAL
TAX REVENUES GENERATED PERSONAL.
ALSO ON THE CREDIT. WE COULD
REALLY YOU WOULD NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THE WAY SHE AND FINALLY.
WE ARE CONCERNED THE PINEY OF
THE STILL. BE JUST LIMITED TAX
INCENTIVES INCLUDING THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT AFTER. FIVE HELLO
BROTHER OR NOT YOU BELIEVE IT.
HALF THE STATE TAKE. ALL WE
KNOW LIMITATION BY PASS A BILL
THAT MISTER BUSINESS FROM THE
YOU TO ARGUE TAX. MAKE THE
STATE IT MAY MAKE THE STATE
ACOSTA HAPPENS ISN'T WRONG.
MESSAGE TO EMPLOYERS ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS CLIMATE
FOR THOSE REASONS WE MUST
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. WATER THE PLEASE
OPEN THE MAINLINE ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
LIKE TO CHAU OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND FOR TO OPEN UP MY
NUMBER FIFTY TWO POINT FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
pLEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECT WILLIAM REMAIN OPPOSED
TO SB NINE SEVEN TWO THANK YOU.
ENACT OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY SIX
LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS STATE FORGET ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE DEATH
SEVENTY TWO. OUTLINED BY MISTER
MCKINLEY AND WALKER THANK YOU.
THE AND NEXT WATER LINE THIRTY
THREE LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. JERRY MEMBERS
KIMBERLY TRIBUTE ON BEHALF OF
TECHNO YOU LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH COUNTY AND CAL.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE.
LOCAL NFL TO MY NUMBER FORTY
NINE MY FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THANK YOU CAN. PLAN
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ELAINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THE NEXT OPEN LINE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THE MORNING CORRECTLY YOUNG
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE RESPECT
CLOSED AT NIGHT OF THE TWO. AND
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING CRAP
ANYMORE WELL ARMY HAVE WITH
VIACOM IN OPPOSITION. I NEXT
OPENED MY NUMBER FIFTY NINE
NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MANY HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES SO
FUSION IN OPPOSITION IF YOU.
AND A A REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER SIXTY THREE
LINES SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. FIVE DON'T
HAPPEN WITH THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFUL OF. AND
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE WOULD OPPOSITION PLEASE.
DO I HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE CANADIAN IF I DON'T
SEE YOU JUST SHALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. THANK YOU I SO
I'M TRYING TO JUST WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND WHAT PROBLEM THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO SOLVE AND WHAT
ACTUALLY IT WOULD SOLVE SO THE
OPPOSITION NOTED THAT LAWMAKERS
ARE READY DO YOU HAVE ACCESS TO
AGGREGATE DATA FROM YOU HAVE TO
BE IS THAT CORRECT SO WE DO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REQUEST
DATA HOWEVER I WILL SAY THIS-
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL BILLS THAT
HAVE COME TO US ON THE WE ARE
HEARING SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
NOT HEARING. THAT ARE
REQUESTING THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION AND THE REALITY IS
THAT LIKE WITH THE FILM TAX
CREDIT WE WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN%
TO EXPAND THAT IF WE HADN'T
SEEN IT WAS WORKING AND HOW DO
WE SEE IF SOMETHING IS WORKING
WE DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION
SO IT'S A KIND OF CATCH TWENTY
TWO. RIGHT IT'S- I KNOW WHAT
YOU CAN DO WE AS A COMMITTEE
KNOW WHAT IS AND ISN'T WORKING
WHICH IS WHY WE CHANGE THE
AMENDMENT. TO NOT POSTING IT ON
THE WEBSITE IT'S NOT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF SHAMING. BUT HOW DO
WE SEE WHAT'S ACTUALLY
FUNCTIONING WELL SO THAT WE
EITHER EXPANDED. OR REMOVE IT
AND- WILL HAVE TRIED WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL SENATORS TRIED TO COME
AT THIS PROBLEM AND IF
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS. I DO
ACTUALLY AGREE THAT THE SHOULD
BE METRICS YOU CAN SEE A MORE
COMPLETE PICTURE AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THE AUTHOR CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND
APPROPRIATIONS. BUT. BECAUSE WE
GOT THAT IN FOR FROM THE TAX
CREDIT WE WERE IT TO EXPAND AND
WAS A GOOD THIS. YOU KNOW SO
THAT'S REALLY THE THAT'S THAT'S
THE ISSUE YEAH BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO CONTEND WITH IN A IN A WAY
THAT IT'S THE REASON WE CHANGE
THE RULES OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
MAKING- MOST OF OUR TAX CREDITS
FIVE YEARS. BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A WAY TO REVIEW THEM AND
WE ARE ASKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION ON EACH BILL NOW WE
REQUIRE IT. WE REQUIRE SECTION
FORTY ONE SO THAT WE HAVE
METRIC SAYS WHICH TO MEASURE IT
HOWEVER A LOT OF ROLE TAX
CREDITS WE DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AND THEIR ON GOING
IN PERPETUITY. WELL I COULDN'T
SO I COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH
YOU THAT WE NEED TO. HAVE EVERY
EVERY PIECE OF DATA POSSIBLE TO
EVALUATE THE EFFICACY OF TAX
CREDITS AND TAX EXPENDITURES.
YES I'M NOT STANDING Y. TAX
PAYER SPECIFIC DISCLOSURE. IS
IN ORDER TO GET THAT. HOW HOW
WOULD YOU GET IT. WOULD YOU
COULD AGGREGATED. BY TAX CREDIT
RATHER THAN BY YOU DON'T NEED
TO HAVE RATED BUT I THINK ACTS
ARTICLE IN THE END OF THIS IS
TO SEE THEM OF THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE IS THERE
IS THAT COMPANY ALTHOUGH HIRING
HERE AND THERE IS A LONG TERM
MORE COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE
TAX CREDIT. THAT I THINK WE'RE
HOPING TO GAIN AT SOME POINT
YEAH I THINK INDIVIDUAL SORT OF
LINE ITEM DATA IT'S VERY HARD
TO YOU ASCERTAIN TRENDS ARE TO
DRAW CONCLUSIONS FROM AND YOU
ACTUALLY NEED AGGREGATE DATA IN
ORDER TO YOU. HAVE YOU PERFORM
ACCURATE ANALYSIS SEPT I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL TAKES IT
FEELS TO ME LIKE IT'S MORE KIND
OF IF YEAH POKING A FINGER IN
THE EYE OF BUSINESS WITHOUT IN
MY VIEW KIND OF AN APPRECIABLE.
WILL BENEFIT. ONE HUNDRED. IN
ONE SO IF I CAN JUST A COUPLE I
THOUGHT THIS WAS- HAD BRACER
FINGER EARLIER SO MY APOLOGIES.
DOCTOR QUIRK. AT SO BUT- I'M
LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS HERE
AND IT JUST SAYS DEFINES GROSS
RECEIPTS THE SAME AS THE FINDER
REVVING TAX CODE SECTION TWENTY
FIVE ONE TWENTY IS THAT THE
LANGUAGE HERE. THAT SAYS THAT
THIS IS- GROSS RECEIPTS ON
WORLDWIDE INCOME. CAN SOMEBODY.
CAN SOMEBODY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I JUST I'M I'M
WONDERING WHY WE DISCERN FRIEND.
OF ONE OR MAYBE THE CONSULTANT-
CAN CAN ANSWER IF SOMEBODY CAN
MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER I GUESS
I'M I'M REALLY WONDERING WHY WE
DECIDED. WHY IT'S THE FIVE
BILLION IS THE NUMBER. AND IT
SEEMS SOMEWHAT NOT SOMEONE IT
IS INCONSISTENT TO THINK THAT
THERE'S SOME COMPANIES THAT ARE
INTERNATIONAL COMPANIES THAT DO
VERY LITTLE BUSINESS HERE. AND
THAT WE WOULD BE GETTING ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION- FROM FROM
FROM THEM EVEN THOUGH THEY
MIGHT ONLY DO A LITTLE BIT OF A
BUSINESS YEAR VERSUS A COMPANY
THAT'S MAYBE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DOES- A LOT OF
BUSINESS HERE SO HOW DO WE COME
UP WITH THAT WITH THAT FIGURE
IN HIS AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS- THIS
IS GROSS WORLDWIDE INCOME IS
THAT RIGHT. IN THE ROOM THREE
FEET YEAH INCOME AND FRANKLY
THE REASON IT WAS PEGGED AT
FIVE BILLION WAYS TO.
RESTRICTOR FENCE IN THE AMOUNT
OF COMPANIES JUST BASICALLY GET
YOU THE TOP TWO HUNDRED
COMPANIES DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN TERMS OF GROSS
RECEIPTS. SO WE'RE NOT GOING
AFTER SMALL BUSINESSES WERE NOT
REACHING AND A- YOU KNOW.
ASKING THE FTP TO PROVIDE TONS
OF INFORMATION- THAT. DOESN'T
IMPACT DECISION MAKING BUT
BASICALLY TAKES A LARGEST
CORPORATIONS. THE LARGEST
COMPANIES WITH THE LARGEST
AMOUNT OF TAX CREDITS. AND
THAT'S THAT'S HOW YOU GOT THERE
IT IT BASICALLY RESTRICTED
SOMEWHERE AROUND TWO HUNDRED.
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA- MISS
RIGHT NOW SO IS IT THE TOTAL
WORLDWIDE REVENUE. I BELIEVE IF
IT'S CALIFORNIA RECEIVED BUT
I'LL HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT GET
BACK TO. WHAT THE- COULD YOU
GIVE WOULD BE FAR WITHOUT. YEAH
IF YOU RIGHT AWAY PLEASE
CHAPTER WILL LISTEN TO A LITTLE
BIT. ANY OTHER COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT- WELL MISTER BLAND SHIPS-
WHAT THE BILL DOES. MADAM
CHAIR- YOU COULD CLOSE AND I
ALSO WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT THE
SENATOR IS ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS SET FORTH IN THE
CANADIAN ALICE'S. WHICH YOU
HAVE ALSO REFERRED TO. IS THAT
CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT. CLOSE.
IT'S SOMETHING I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR THEIR QUESTIONS TODAY YOU
KNOW IT THIS IT HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE TO FIND THE RIGHT WAY
TO REALLY ANALYZE THESE BILL
ANALYZE TESE TAX CREDITS WE
HAVE LOOKED NOT JUST FROM OUR
COMMITTEE LEVEL BUT ON AND OFF
BASIS HOW TO BEST DO THAT. AND
THIS IS. PLANE FIRST. IN THAT
HOUSES THAT WE REALLY DO NEED
TO TAKE TAKE- AT SOME POINT
TAKE A STAB AT. WITH THAT. WHEN
MISTER BURNING COMES BACK TO
ANSWER HIS QUESTIONS WE CAN I
RESPECTFULLY ACOSTA NAY ABOUT.
LET ME SAID THAT. MORE
REFLECTING ON A VERY DIFFICULT
YEAR AND. I THINK THAT SENATOR
JACKSON'S BILL HAD SHE TAKEN
OUT THE COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE
BEEN A BETTER WAY TO GO ABOUT
THIS. BUT AT THE MOMENT THIS IS
THE ONLY VEHICLE WOULD HAVE.
HAVE WITH THE CHAIRS THE
COMMISSION WILL WAIT FOR MR NON
LOOKS LIKE HE'S COMING BACK TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. I'VE BEEN.
ARE BETTER FOR THE- REVENUE TAX
COMMITTEE CONTROLLED ON THE
SENATE SIDE AND YOU HAVE TO BE
THAT IT'S WORLDWIDE REVENUES
FIVE BILLION. AND WORLDWIDE
GROSS FOR FREE. TWELVE ONE
NEVER SHARED WITH ANYTHING ELSE
TO SELL. HOW NO I DO WE DID
HAVE A COUPLE AND TO YOUR
COMMENTS WE DID HAVE A FEW
BILLS TO LOOK AT THAT WERE AND
THAT IN THIS VEIN- BOTH BILLS
FACE THEIR CHALLENGES WITH THIS
COMMITTEE- AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE AUTHOR MOVING FORWARD
SHOULD LOOK AT SOME OF THE
METRICS THAT ARE ANY OTHER BILL
HOWEVER THE- MECHANISM BY WHICH-
THERE'S- I CAN ISN'T ANY OTHER%
BILL THAT. WERE NOT FUNCTIONAL
FOR MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
SO- I DO I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE METRICS AS THEY
MOVED INTO APPROPRIATIONS BUT
THEY DO TH LIKE I SAY. LIKE I
SAID WE HAVE A LOT OF TAX
CREDITS THAT ARE GOING. USE BUT
NOT REALLY BENEFITING THE
COMMUNITY IN THE WAY THEY
SHOULD. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY QUESTION I WILL.
THE OF THE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
FOR NINE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SEVEN SEVEN. MOVED BY MISTER
CHOOSE BLINDNESS. MOTION IS DAY
PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MISTER RUFF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BURKE HI
BURKE FIVE TWO. CHIU AYE GRAY.
YEAH RIGHT NOW LEVINE HI LEVINE
AYE MAYES NO MAYES NO MULLIN.
PETRIE-NORRIS YEAH
PETRIE-NORRIS NO QUIRK. QUIRK
FIVE RIVAS. RIVAS I'D DOLLY NO
CALLING NO. THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES IN HIS OWN CALL. MORE
THAN CHAIR THE CARD THANK YOU
DOCTOR CREEK NEXT UP WE HAVE
FILE ITEM SIX SB FOURTEEN OH
NINE BY SENATOR CAFIERO CENTER
PROBABLY ARE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT. ACCORDING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. START OFF BY
SAYING I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES- AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE AND NOW AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING SO HARD WITH ME I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. SB
FOURTEEN OH NINE WOULD REQUIRE
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. TO
CREATE A PLAN TO INCREASE THE
CLAIMS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT THE
CAL THE ITC.AND THE FEDERAL
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
INCLUDING STUDYING ALTERNATIVE
FILING SYSTEMS. THE KELLY I. T.
T. C. IS ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN
POVERTY. STILL MANY ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS DO NOT
KNOW ABOUT THE BENEFITS AND
FAIL THE CLASS. FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TAXED YEAR F.
T. B. ESTIMATED ONE POINT TWO
FIVE MILLION ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS
WOULD NOT CLEAN THE CAL E. I.
T. C. TWO THIRDS OF WHICH DO
NOT FILE A TAX RETURN. WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AN UNPRECEDENTED
FINANCIAL CRISIS AS A RESULT OF
THE COLBERT NINETEEN VIRUS.
FAMILIES WHO ARE STRUGGLE
STRUGGLING BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
NOW FACE EXTREME FINANCIAL
STRESS. DIRECTING THE FTP TO
STUDY ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO PAY
THE CREDIT TO FAMILIES THAT ARE
ALREADY QUALIFY. FOR IT BUT DO
NOT GET IT IS CRITICAL IN THESE
TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES HARD
WORKING FAMILIES NEED ECONOMIC
SUPPORT AS EFFICIENCY
EFFICIENTLY AND RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH MAYBE A
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JAMIE OFTEN WITH THE TIPPING
POINT COMMUNITY. KAREN ROBUST A
STUDENT LEADER WITH THE MLK
FREEDOM CENTER. I'M WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH AND JAMIE AUSTIN. THANK
YOU CAN YES. GOOD MORNING MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JAMIE
AUTHENTICATING QUICK MUNITY
POVERTY BY THE ORGANIZATION AND
THE BAY WE'RE PROUD BONTA ALONG
WITH I CAN SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION AND GREAT INSTITUTE AND
CHILD ARE BEING CALIFORNIA. IN
CALIFORNIA AN ESTIMATED SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION LIVE IN
POVERTY MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE MANY THE COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
AMONG POVERTY FIGHTING TOOLS WE
KNOW THAT TAX CREDITS ARE
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE. THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT WHY TO CREATE
A CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT FIVE YEARS AGO IN TO
EXPAND IT LAST YEAR EVEN MORE
WORKING FAMILIES EQUALLY WIDE
WITH THE BLOOD OF THE
LEGISLATURE ACTION THE PATH THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT TO
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES LEVEL
AND OUR STATE. HOWEVER DESPITE
THE AFFECTING THE AND GET THAT
MANY OF THOSE OF THE BALL BACK
UP TO ONE IN FIVE ARE NOT
RECEIVING THEM TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND STATE AND FEDERAL
CREDIT THROUGH MADE UNCLAIMED
EACH. YEAR WHY IS THAT. MANY
MAY NOT HAVE THE IN. ABOUT THE
CREDIT ORDER LG. BUT RESEARCH
SEVEN POINT FIND IT JEFF THAT
LISTING OUTREACH EFFORTS ALLOW
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT TO INCREASE
UPTAKE. IN ADDITION WHAT
MOTIVATES THE BILL IS THAT. TO
RECEIVE THE FACT CREDIT
HOUSEHOLD LEFT FILE TAX RETURNS
EVEN AFTER INCOME FALL BELOW
THE FOUGHT KILEY THRESHOLD.
FILING IT'S TIME INTENT THE
BURDEN FROM AND COMPLEX FOR THE
TYPICAL TAX FILER BUT IT
PARTICULARLY SO FOR WORKING
FAMILIES AND FOR THAT CAN BE I
KEEP THE- WE NEED OTHER TOOL.
MORE THAN EVER WE WANT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE CREDIT TO RECEIVE THEM TO
IMPROVE THE ECONOMIC SECURITY
OF WORKING FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. FIFTY ALLOW THAT
TO UNDERSTAND THE BARRIERS
ACTING UP TAKE A WHAT
ALTERNATIVE COULD BE DEVELOPED
TO REDUCE THE BURDEN OF FILING.
IF THE ATTIC TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO IDENTIFY.
THE BARRIERS AND TO RECOMMEND
COLLISIONS. THE REPORT FAMILIES
IN NEED WE MET DETERMINE THE
BEST STRATEGY. THIS BILL DOES
THAT. TAKE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT MS ROADHOUSE. MORNING
THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
BURKE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GOT INTO
HIGH I AM A STUDENT AT THE A
COMMUNITY LEARNING THEIR IN
ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA ONLY DIDN'T
LEADER AT THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER. I'M
TODAY TO ASK THAT YOU PASS
SENATE BILL FORTINO NINE THAT
WILL GREATLY HELP LOW INCOME
FAMILIES LIKE MINE. IN SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD AND I'VE BEEN RATES
BY TWO WONDERFUL HEROES MY
GRANDMOTHER AND MOTHER MY
GRANDMOTHER WORKED AT A MINIMUM
WAGE JOB WITHOUT BENEFIT VERY
RETAIL CHAIN. THROUGHOUT HER
LIFE SHE HAD HAD UNSTABLE
HOUSING MY MOTHER IS A SINGLE
PARENT AND SHE WORKS VERY HARD
TO SUPPORT ME. MANY OTHER
FAMILIES IN MY COMMUNITY BASED
STRUGGLE LIKE IF YOU MANY
STUDENTS AT THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER ARE
IN LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT
OFTEN HAVE A HARD TIME PAYING
FOR NECESSITY. SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES. HAVE EXPERIENCED
BEING HOMELESS. IT ON THE OF
CHILDREN IN THE HOME.
CALIFORNIA'S EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT DELIVERY BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
DOLLARS AT THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
DOLLARS. MANY PEOPLE DO NOT
KNOW THAT THEY QUALIFY FOR THE
CREDIT OR HOW TO FILE IT. THE
STUDY REQUIRED UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD HELP INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF ELIGIBLE FAMILY THAT
RECEIVED YEAH I. THE F. B.
FOURTEEN OH NINE REQUIRED THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TAKES OR
HOW TO MAKE TAX FILING LESS
BURDENSOME FOR ELIGIBLE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. READY TO
VALUE WITH WORKABILITY AND TO
INFORM WHETHER SUCH A PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA. WE ASK THAT YOU
APPROVE SB FORTINO NINE BECAUSE
SOME OF OUR LOWEST INCOME HARD
WORKING FAMILIES MAYBE MAKING
MONEY THEY DESPERATELY NEED.
EVEN THE AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE DOLLARS WITH
THEHELPFUL FAMILIES THAT
CALENDAR CARING FOR THEMSELVES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
OVER THE LINE FOR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ELECTRICAL TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO LINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER THIRTY NINE ONE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING
THIS IS JACKIE LONG LOOK AND
SHOP ON THE- CALIFORNIA. COAST
UNDER THAT. OF THE BILL THAT
YOU CAN USE THE WORK OF THAT
MEETING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY TASK FORCE.
WHICH YOU CHAMPION MADAM CHAIR-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ABOUT. THANK YOU. IN ORDER LINE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE ONE TWENTY
NINE LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS
IS IRIS HE CAN'T HEAR ME. YEAH
HI SPEAKING SAID IRIS I THANK
YOU I OUR TAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE CELL. AND NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN LINE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THIS IS DONNA CALLING
IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. AND
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING THIS IS KERRY ONLY WITH
ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION ONE OF THE PAD COULD
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. YOUR AYE
VOTE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NECKLINE OPEN UP MY NUMBER
SIXTY ONE LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE'RE
NOT RESPONSIBLE ONE TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY NINE NINE SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN ENDS GO
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIXTY
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. IF YOUR MIND IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. HELLO
THIS IS CARLA THE METHOD DIEGO
WITH THE DELUXE WHAT THE
FOUNDATION AND WE ENCOURAGE IT
I BOTH FOR SB FORTINO NINE. AND
AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FOR AN EXPERT AT SPENT A
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE TO
OPEN UP MY NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
LINE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS BECKY- FUND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER APART-
INDIVIDUAL SHOWING SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE. WITH
THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
MAIN LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WAIT WAIT DON'T TELL
ME TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO ONE TO AN
UPRIGHT POSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOVE THE BILL. RIGHT SEEING
NONE OH SORRY YEAH. IF I IF I
CAN- I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF THE
ATC AND I IT YEP EVEN THE
FEDERAL LEVEL- IT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME- I THINK WE IN
INSTITUTED THE A. T. C. FOR
MEMBER CORRECTLY MAYBE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY. SIXTEEN
SO IT'S STILL ROAD NEW IN IN
CALIFORNIA- THE ONE THING I'M
I'M WONDERING WITH THIS IS THIS
IS JUST A STUDY BILL OR IS THIS
ARE WE TRYING TO SET US UP
POLICY WITH IT BECAUSE THE
REASON I SAY THAT IS IT BE
GREAT TO NOT HAVE TO FILE A
EIGHT RETURN FOR THE LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT WANT ONE HAVE TO.
FILE A FILE IT TURNED PURPOSE
OF THE EIGHT PIECE AS IT'S CRAP.
IS THE INTENT ON PEOPLE WORKING
IF THEY WORK AND HAVE INCOME
THAN IT GET A REFUNDABLE CREDIT
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THEIR WORK
THAT'S IT HE C. SUPPORT THE
POSTED VIA. SOME DEBATE WE'VE
HAD SOME TO. COUPLE BEERS
REGARD THIS OFTEN. WHAT IS SELF
EMPLOYED SHE GETS AND YET C. OR
NOT WOULD. IT ARE THE IS THAT
GONNA BE STUDIED IN THIS- THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE SELF
EMPLOYED WHO DON'T HAVE TEN
NINETY NINES- WHAT DATE- GET A-
A REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT WITHOUT
FILING ANY. A TAX RETURN AS
WELL SO YOU KNOW HOW HOW DEEP
IS THIS GONNA GO. BUT AGAIN
IT'S SEVERAL QUESTIONSIN THERE
BUT- IF IT'S JUST A STUDY
BUILDING- CASE JUST TO STUDY
BILL- BUT IT'S ACTUALLY SETTING
POLICY- GIVING DIRECTION. AND
THEN I'VE GOT SOME CONCERNS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- MY
INTENT ORIGINALLY WAS TO. HAVE
THEM FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO. TO DO IT WITHOUT
HAVING TO FILE A TAX RETURN.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DIFFICULTY OF GIVING THAT KIND
OF DIRECTION. WHEN THERE MAY BE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES THAT MAKE
MORE SENSE AND THERE WERE TWO
PURPOSES ACTUALLY ONE IS TO.
ENCOURAGE THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION BUT DE BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
INFORMATION ON. THESE
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUALS BUT ALSO
TO GET THEM THINKING. WHAT ARE
THE ALTERNATIVES. THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE AND HOW CAN WE
ENCOURAGE THAT DIRECTION IT AND
PART OF THE REASON IS BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN SPENDING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
THE MILLIONS. TRYING TO GET THE
WORD OUT AND THE RESEARCH THAT
WAS DONE BY THE TIPPING POINT
COMMUNITY- WAS THAT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT. WE SPENT THAT MONEY.
MANY PEOPLE STILL DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S A CREDIT AVAILABLE TO
THEM- OR IF THEY DO. IT'S
ENOUGH OF A HASSLE TO FILL OUT
PAPERWORK. IF YOU DON'T KNOW
OUR TAX SYSTEM AND THAT. THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE AFRAID DOING IT
THEY JUST DON'T DO IT AND SO
THE QUESTION BECOMES YOU KNOW
IS WAITING IT MAY BE FOR
EXAMPLE. TO PRE FILL OUT A FORM
THEY GET SENT TO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TB THINKS MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE AND THAT WOULD BE
MAYBE ONE ALTERNATIVE BUT
RATHER THAN PRE JUDGING WHAT
THE ALTERNATIVES ARE IT'S A
STUDY REPORT. HOW WEAK ANDEXT.
AND MAKE IT A FOR PEOPLE TO
ACCESS THIS THIS BENEFIT THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO THAT THEY
DON'T THEY MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT.
AND DOES IT INCLUDE A SELF
EMPLOYED OR WOULD IT JUST BE
FOR W. TWO. YOU KNOW IT DOES
NOT EXPLICIT IN THE LANGUAGE
THOUGH MIKE MY READING OF IT IS
THEY WOULD EXPLORE EVERYTHING.
AND YOUR COMMENTS QUESTIONS. IN
OUR PURVIEW WE'RE NOT CHANGING
THE ESSENCE OF THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT OR CHANGING
THELANGUAGE ON BY THE INCOME
TAX CREDIT IS CURRENTLY PROCESS
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO SEE IF
THERE IS A WAY FOR THOSE WHO
DON'TAND IT'S JUST TRYING TO
SEE IF THERE AND IF IT'S THE
BEST ALTERNATIVE TO HAVE- A
WHETHER IT'S A NO TAX RETURN OR
WHATEVER THE POSSIBLE-
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD BE SO THAT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT. SO
IT'S DONE A BILL THAT IS NOT
TING THE ESSENCE OF EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT THEY ARE
CONTACT THE IS TRYING TO. SURE
THAT ALL THE THAT ARE. ARE
GETTING. AND THEN THE THERE'D
BE A POLICY WOULD COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT YEAH I JUST WANT TO
ASK MAKE THAT ABUNDANTLY YES OR
NINE THINK THERE WERE NOT
SITTING ANYTHING THIS IS JUST
THIS IS A VERY DO LITTLE LITTLE
WORK. AND THEN BRING IT BACK
RIGHT US TO BE ABLE TO GO IN
AND WHETHER WE WOULD SUPPORT-
THOSE ONES THAT RESERVATION WAS
AND IN THE ORIGINAL BILL IF YOU
LOOK AT IT AND HAD NO EIGHT
WITH NO INCOME TAX RETURN WE
TOOK THAT OUT AND I BELIEVE THE
SENATOR IS ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. WE TOOK
OUT THAT IT WOULD BE A NO
INCOME TAX RETURN BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S THE BEST
WAY TO GO ABOUT IT SO THIS
WOULD BE A STUDY THAT WILL
ANALYZE WHAT IS THE BEST WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THOSE
THAT. THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT AS IT
STANDS TODAY HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THEY GET IT. IT'S A STUDY
BILL OR NOT SETTING POLICY OF
THE SUPPORT OF THAT TODAY.
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION THAT CLARIFICATION
I ASK YOUR- THE MISTRUST
CALDERON I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
MOTION WE NEED TO SEE. A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PAGE
PETRIE-NORRIS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
AND- BURKE FIVE TWO FIVE. FIVE
GREAT. GRAY NOT VOTING LEVINE
HI LEVINE I MAYES ARE MESA FIVE
ONE. RIGHT NO ONE HI FUTURE
NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS FIVE FOUR.
FOUR FIVE RIVAS RIVAS HI DOLLY.
DOLLY NOT VOTING. THE BILL HAS
EIGHT BUCKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. RIGHT SO I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A VOTE CHANGE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY WOULD LIKE TO
CHANGE HIS VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. HE DIDN'T ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. GREAT. RAY
NOT VOTING. LEVINE HI THANK YOU
LEVINE I ONCE OUR. ONE FIVE. OR.
YEAH. KING MOVE TO ITEM. WE
SERVE A BONE CALL RAIN. TO
THOSE. MR A FRIEND SHE DOODLES
ON CALL. THE FIRST BILL ON CALL
IS SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FOUR
BY SENATOR MITCHELL. CALLING
ABSENT CHEESE MON HI MULLIN HI.
THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES IN IS
OUT. SECOND BELL ON CALLED.
SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR SKINNER. CALLING
ABSENTEES MORE FIVE POINT FIVE
THAT BILL SIX VOTES AND IS OUT.
YEAH. YEAH. WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
REVAN TAX IS OVER.